the number one thing that screws up
people's ability to build wealth is
their friends and family we figured out
personal finances 80%
Behavior it's only 20% head knowledge
the mathematics of becoming wealthy are
really about the sixth grade level if
you can do multiplication you can
understand compound
interest and so it it's it's it's within
your grasp you don't have to be a uh PhD
andth matics to do it but the problem
with understanding that personal finance
is 80% behavior is then you have to
think okay what affects Behavior
behavior is all about relationships it's
not all about it but I mean it's one of
the relationships your marriage
relationship your kids